pourquoi s'arrêter à un héros
quand on peut tous de les faire
découvrir
les roues ne laissons pas ils sont
forgés dans les ténèbres il y a encore
de l'espoir pour le multivers
s'est marié
on ne recule jamais devant une bataille
exact commandant c'est maintenant ou
jamais
des zombies super idée
yann tempête qui approche
à lui
pas besoin de plans
j'ai un bouclier
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui était arrivé tu vas
comprendre
vibrer avec les plus grands héros du
multivers
ou minuscules si vous voyez ce que je
veux dire
vous connaissez le dicton quand il ya
plus d'espoir on s'en remet aux canards
j'ai jamais entendu qui que ce soit à
dire ça
[Musique]